michael wie ist die situation jetzt am
frühen morgen dort
guten morgen patricia also ich gehe
jetzt schon mal sofort zur seite da kann
man sich das ganze mal kurz an gucken
der festnehmen kann mal ein bisschen so
man sieht dass der verkehr ein wenig
rollt die polizei hat den linken
fahrstreifen komplett gesperrt und hier
haben sich wirklich dramatische szenen
abgespielt in der letzten nacht das ist
ja gerade in dem beitrag auch schon
angeklungen ich muss mich hier ein
bisschen festhalten weil sonst haben wir
den nächsten unfall ja also die a2 war
tatsächlich mit fast 70 kilometern stau
belegt wir haben gerade kurz hier über
die leitplanke mit einem lastwagenfahrer
sprechen können und er hat gesagt er
hätte vier stunden hier in der kälte
gestanden man muss sagen dass natürlich
die ganzen lkw viele davon einfach den
weg versperrt haben sie standen halt
quer und es ging dann halt nichts mehr
viele auch vielleicht mit den falschen
reifen das nächste problem wenn die lkw
quer stehen kommen die pkws natürlich
auch nicht mehr durch dann konnten
schwerlich rettungsgassen gebildet
werden dann musste man irgendwie
versuchen mit schwerem gerät wenigstens
eine schneise zu bilden und dann sind
die rettungskräfte das thw und das rote
kreuz durch den stau gefahren und haben
wenigstens versucht manche der leute die
im stau stehen mit getränken und decken
zu versorgen
allerdings habe ich gerade mit meinem
kollegen markus brekenkamp hier aus
ostwestfalen gesprochen und er sagt die
polizei habe eben gesagt dass es hier
soll wahrscheinlich noch sehr sehr lange
andauern kann bis sich die situation
normalisiert was mich ein bisschen
wundert ich habe jetzt drei tage in
niedersachsen gestanden das ist jetzt
hier vom bielefelder kreuz nicht allzu
weit entfernt es galt bis gestern abend
eine ein fahrverbot bis 24 uhr da habe
ich ja gestern in den schalten schon
angemerkt dass ich mir das kaum
vorstellen kann das dann wirklich der
verkehr wieder flüssig fließt hier in
ostwestfalen gab es auch bis 18 uhr oder
in ganz nrw ein verbot für schwerlast
lkw
allerdings sind trotzdem ganz ganz viele
gefahren und bin einer stunde können
sich nicht so viele lkw ansammeln die
eigentlich nicht fahren dürfen also da
muss man auch sagen dass da ganz klar
was schief gelaufen ist
michael wie schätzel es ein wie wird es
heute ja es ist ja keine entspannung
bezüglich des wetters angesagt dort auf
der a2 weitergehen ja also ich gehe noch
mal eben zur seite
dann kann man es vielleicht nochmal ein
bisschen sich angucken also es geht hier
wirklich auch im schneckentempo vorwärts
ich glaube dass ich das hier über den
tag tatsächlich nicht vollends
entspannen wird man kann ja noch mal
eben auf die linke fahrspur gucken auf
da ist wirklich da geht es aber sobald
er auch einen lkw
wir werden gegrüßt ein lkw quer steht
wird dann natürlich auch wieder nichts
gehen also ich glaube dass wir
tatsächlich noch den ganzen tag andauern
man muss aber auch sagen dass die
einsatzkräfte die rettungskräfte alle
rahmen sieht hier ist wenigstens noch
gute laune
das hilft ja auch nichts wenn man hier
zehn stunden im stau steht wenn man da
auch noch sauer ist dann passiert ja
tatsächlich gar nichts aber noch mal
zurück zur wettersituation also momentan
schneide es nicht also nur ein bisschen
es wird aber bis zu minus 15 grad
erwartet und ich glaube nicht dass sich
die wettersituation hier tatsächlich
entspannen wird
dann können wir einfach nur noch sagen
dass natürlich das rote kreuz das thw
und alle wirklich im einsatz sind um zu
versuchen dass die leute die jetzt hier
im stau stehen dass sie es wenigstens
ein bisschen warm haben ganz ganz viele
haben natürlich auch wenig getankt die
haben sich dann auch nicht so richtig
auf diese situation vorbereitet dass sie
hatten wenig getränke wenig zu essen und
teilweise natürlich auch wenn man über
stunden dann die den wagen laufen lässt
um die heizung irgendwie intakt zu
halten
dann wird auch irgendwann der sprit alle
natürliches der adac hier auch in höchst
einsatz
das ist deren job aber natürlich wenn
hier über 30 40 50 kilometer stau sind
wie es in der vergangenen nacht war dann
kommen auch diese profis für für solche
rettungswagen irgendwann dann an ihre
grenzen
nichtsdestotrotz ist es muss es behoben
werden es muss irgendwie weitergehen und
da wird versuchen hier alle was zu tun
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren